e aí
e o meu bisavô era do tipo de pessoa que
atravessava a rua para não andar na
mesma calçada que um negro o meu avô
fazia piadas sobre um namorado que uma
prima teve dizendo que só apareciam os
dentes dele nas fotografias o meu pai
até hoje os expressões racistas apesar
disso nenhuma dessas situações nunca me
pareceu normal ou aceitável e acho que
empate foi graças a um livro
as negras raízes de alex harley eu li
esse livro quando eu tinha uns treze
anos de idade era um livro grande como a
600 páginas que eu li em 3 dias nele eu
acompanhei a trajetória de kunta kintê
que foi levado da gâmbia para os estados
unidos e das sete gerações seguintes até
chegar no alex harley o autor do livro
anos depois quando discurso da dívida
histórica ganhou força no brasil
especialmente em meio a debates a
respeito das cotas raciais nas
universidades eu não tive dificuldades
para entender essa questão negras raízes
já tinha me preparado para isso eu não
vim aqui fazer a defesa desse livro
específico por mais que eu realmente é
recomende a leitura o que eu quero
chamar a atenção é para o quanto a
leitura de um livro fez com que eu
entendesse a situação de um
eu não pertenço eu não sou negra meus
antepassados não foram arrancados de sua
terra e cultura e forçados a trabalhar
para outras pessoas mas eu consegui
entender um pouco dessa situação a
partir de uma narrativa o suficiente
para que eu conseguisse me posicionar
como apoiadora da luta do movimento
negro isso é empatia e isso é uma das
coisas mais bonitas que a arte ea
literatura no meu caso específico pode
nos proporcionar sim arte nos
proporcionar prazer estético
entretenimento emoções variadas mas
também proporcionar empatia a capacidade
de a gente se identificar com outro
descente com outro de se colocar no
lugar do outro e de ver o mundo a partir
de outro lugar é lógico que praia
e a gente precisa ler narrativas que
fujam do padrão e é lógico que para isso
a gente precisa entender o que que é o
padrão uma pesquisa coordenada pela
professora da universidade de brasília e
doutor em teoria literária regina del
castagno mostrou que 78 por cento dos
protagonistas dos romances brasileiros
inscritos entre 2005 e 2015 são brancos
e seis por cento negros apenas um por
cento indígena isso só olhando para cor
questões como classe social gênero
orientação sexual também tem
disparidades enormes em resumo o
principal personagem do romance
brasileiro ainda é homem branco
heterossexual de classe média alta e
morador de são paulo ou rio de janeiro
eu poderia dizer aqui que isso reflete
bastante o perfil do escritor brasileiro
e que isso também deveria ser colocado
em debate mas isso é uma conversa para
uma outra hora o que é importante
ressaltar é que não é esse tipo de
narrativa que faz com que criemos
empatia por grupos diferentes esse tipo
de narrativa somente reforça o que já é
sabido
e eu não sou um homem branco
heterossexual de classe média alta mas
eu sei como um homem assim se sente em
diversas situações porque muitos
produtos culturais e livros e produtos
artísticos enfocam esse homem mas eu não
sei como se sente uma mulher indígena
quando ela vê um filho ser xingado no
semáforo eu não sei como se sente uma
mulher negra quando ela se descobre
lésbica eu preciso de mais narrativas
demais variedades nas narrativas para
que eu consiga cada vez mais entender as
multiplicidades das vidas humanas eu
publiquei recentemente um livro de
contos somente com protagonistas
femininas foi uma decisão pensada de
antemão não aconteceu por acaso por uma
decisão política eu não me sinto
proibida de criar personagens masculinos
mas em relação a esse
e eu pensei para que as narrativas
masculinas já estão aí são múltiplas as
narrativas sobre mulheres ainda não
foram suficientemente exploradas ainda
muito que se falar em prova disso é que
muitas mulheres se identificaram com a
situações contadas no livro situações
essas que elas achavam as vezes que eram
somente vividas por elas e vários homens
que leram o livro disseram que passaram
a ver as mães as avós e outras mulheres
de suas vidas de forma diferente ou seja
a leitura tenho a empatia necessária
para que eles conseguissem sentir com
outro isso é mágico então se eu puder
deixar duas mensagens finais eu gostaria
de pedir aos escritores e as escritoras
e são homens brancos e cogitem a
possibilidade de criar personagens a
partir dos dramas que conhecem e dos
lugares que ocupam nós precisamos dessas
narrativas para nos conectarmos uns aos
outros e para conseguimos entender cada
vez mais o com diversos somos enquanto
sociedade e gostaria de pedir aos
leitores que se permitam conhecer outras
narrativas que se permitam sentir com
outro de outros grupos e com outras
perspectivas eu prometo que vocês vão
sair disso muito maiores do que vocês
entraram assim como eu sei que eu saí
maior da minha leitura de negras raízes
é muito obrigada